muy buenos días las autoridades peruanas
señalan que al diario 300 indocumentados
más de 300 indocumentados cruzan la
frontera entre perú y ecuador y la
mayoría de ellos son ciudadanos
venezolanos y esto representa un peligro
según sus propias palabras para
potenciar los contagios del cobi 19 en
estos momentos perú está afrontando una
segunda ola de 'el hobbit' 19 es por eso
que el gobierno peruano dispuso que más
de 1200 efectivos de las fuerzas armadas
se posicionen entre la frontera entre
perú y ecuador y se busca sellar más de
30 pasos ilegales que existen en esa
jurisdicción el gobierno peruano ha
dispuesto además que los organismos de
inteligencia conjuntamente con la
policía y la dirección general de
migraciones realicen operativos para
identificar y sancionar a aquellos
ciudadanos venezolanos que ilegalmente
se encuentren en territorio peruano
precisamente las autoridades señalan que
existen
las que trafican con migrantes que
operan en esa zona y tratan de erradicar
los todo esto se suscitó luego de que un
ciudadano peruano publicar a través de
redes sociales el paso de un camión con
30 o más de 30 ciudadanos venezolanos en
momentos en que la frontera se encuentra
cerrada y teóricamente no debe de cruzar
nadie nadie debe de ingresar ni salir
del territorio peruano esto creó un
escándalo y fue resaltado por diversos
medios de comunicación que hizo una dura
crítica al gobierno del presidente de
sagasti las autoridades prefieren cortar
por lo sano y realizar una coordinación
a última hora con las autoridades
ecuatorianas para realizar este
operativo militar conjunto